what's going on people in this video
I'll be breaking down the first season
of Jiu Jitsu Kaizen in around 30 minutes
or less and by the end you'll understand
everything you need to know going into
season two to make the timeline flow
easier one important detail I want to
explain right from the beginning is the
existence of cursed energy inju jitsuka
is in cursed energy is a mystical power
source created from negative emotions
and for most people their curse energy
just leaks out whenever they feel angry
or upset over time all this leaking
curse energy merges together in certain
places to form invisible monsters known
as cursed Spirits although 99 of the
population can't see them these Spirits
kill thousands of people every single
year and the only ones who are trying to
prevent this are the Jujitsu Sorcerers
for now the two main things you should
remember about Sorcerers is that they're
actually able to see curses unlike
everyone else and they can harness their
own curse energy to activate superhuman
abilities
with that explained season one of Jiu
Jitsu Kaizen starts off with Yuji
itadori who's a freakishly Strong high
school student and member of the occult
research Club the aim of this small club
is for students to theorize about
Paranormal Activity but in yuji's case
there's a very personal reason why he
joined for nearly all of his life he was
raised by his granddad Mr itadori who's
now currently in hospital on the verge
of death because of that Yuji wanted to
join a club that required the least
amount of commitment so that he'd have
enough free time to visit the hospital
after school in episode 1 Yuji visits
his Grandad for the final time and
during their last conversation it's
implied that Mr itadori has no other
friends or family who would want to be
there with his dying breaths he
basically warns his grandson not to end
up alone like him and he says that Yuji
should use his strength to help people
following that Mr itadori quietly passes
away but it doesn't take long for a jiu
jitsu sorcerer to then show up at the
hospital the name of this young sorcerer
is Megami fushiguro and he was sent on a
mission to find a dangerous object for a
bit of context here a thousand years ago
there was an evil sorcerer called sukuna
who was arguably the greatest of all
time and when he died his soul was
divided into 20 fingers each of these
fingers contains a Godly amount of
cursed energy and it just so happens
that one of them was sealed inside a box
at yuji's school fushiguro's job was to
retrieve that box before it began to
hurt anyone however by the time he
arrived it had already been taken this
is what brings us back to the hospital
where Yuji confesses that it was him who
found the cursed object but since he
didn't know what it was he gave it to
his friends in the occult research Club
in doing so he put their lives in
serious danger because at the school
they were currently in the process of
unsealing the finger according to
fushiguro this is the worst thing that
could happen as he reveals that if the
seal is broken cursed spirits will be
attracted to the area and will likely
kill yuji's friends it's why in this
scene the two of them rushed to the
school as fast as they can and as megamy
enters the building he's confronted by a
bunch of creepy looking curses luckily
for him he's able to fight most of them
off by using his curse technique and I'm
just going to take a second to quickly
explain what this is a curse technique
is a unique ability that a sorcerer has
to be born with and the nature of the
technique will vary from person to
person for example there's a technique
that manipulates blood a technique that
turns sound waves into weapons and when
it comes to fushiguro his technique is
called the 10 Shadows the way it works
is that there are 10 different hand
gestures that he can make each of which
creates a shadow and from those Shadows
he's able to summon up to 10 different
shikigami in episode 1 he summons his
Divine dogs to tear apart the curse
spirits but at this stage in the
timeline there are several other
shikigami that he hasn't managed to
control anyway on the outside of the
school Yuji was told to wait here by
fushiguro but after remembering what his
Grandad said about helping others he
decides to try and do something using
his insane strength its story jumps all
the way up to the fourth floor of the
school and manages to save his friends
from being eaten by a curse prior to
this Mom government usually had never
seen a Casper in his life but in needed
situations and in places with Godly
amounts of Christ energy non-sorcerers
like him are sometimes able to see them
as itadori then picks up the cursed
object fushiguro reveals that the reason
Spirits are attracted to sukin's finger
is because swallowing all that curse
energy would make them more powerful
seconds later the group then gets
attacked by the toughest curse so far
and during the chaos it beats up Mega me
to the point where he can't really focus
on his technique at the same time Yuji
puts up a good fight but as a
non-sorcerer it's impossible to kill
Spirits with his bare hands that's why
after it begins to overpower him he
decides that the best way to win is to
swallow sukin's finger for himself based
on what fushigura said Yuji assumes that
eating this will give him a ton of
cursed energy although what he doesn't
know is that the thing is poisonous to
humans from the sidelines megamy watches
on in horror fully expecting its Dory to
die from this but out of nowhere
sukini's ancient Soul takes a serve his
body the anime described this as a one
in a million outcome that isn't supposed
to happen and within seconds
effortlessly wipes out the cursed Spirit
surprisingly though despite him being
the strongest cursed object of all time
yuji's Soul somehow manages to regain
control this is good news since it means
that for now sukuda can't go on a
rampage but from megami's perspective
it's still the worst day of his life
thinking that sukuna might still be in
control fushiguro prepares to sacrifice
himself by making the hand gesture to
summon his most uncontrollable and
overpowered chickagami had he followed
through with this is guaranteed that
both himself and Yuji would have been
killed but fortunately for them Gojo
shows up before it happens in the world
of jujitsu Sorcerers saturor Gojo is by
far the most talented human alive and he
also happens to be megami's teacher his
Limitless curse technique gives him the
power to manipulate space itself and as
a result he can teleport erase Mata blow
things away make himself physically
Untouchable and and he never runs out of
cursed energy due to his special eyes
now after arriving at fushiguro's
location Gojo takes an interest in Yuji
and his unique ability to suppress
sukuna's Soul a rare Talent like this
could be incredibly valuable but sadly
according to Jujitsu regulations anyone
possessed by a curse object can't be
allowed to survive regardless Megami
urges his teacher to find a way to save
yuji's Life As for the next day Gojo
brings it to Dory to jiu jitsu high
hidden away in the mountains of Tokyo
Jujutsu High School is where generations
of sorcerers have gone to master their
techniques including Gojo himself the
school is managed by a group of old men
referred to as the higher ups and these
guys are responsible for making the
regulations unsurprisingly once they
found out about yuji's situation they
ordered for him to be put to death but
Gojo made a convincing argument for
delaying the execution for the past
Thousand Years nothing has ever been
strong enough to destroy tsukuna but
thanks to itadori they now have a real
chance Gojo's idea is that before Yuji
gets executed he should join Jiu Jitsu
High where they can use him to track
down all the remaining fingers once
that's done Yuji can then eat the rest
of sukuna's Soul so that when he gets
executed tsukunu will die at the same
time the higher Ops agree to this
proposal since it's their best chance to
finally defeat the king of curses while
from yuji's point of view even though he
doesn't want to get executed he was fine
with going along with the plan for two
reasons the first reason is that by
eliminating sukuna fewer people will die
from curses and so in this way itadori
is helping others just like his Grandad
wanted the second reason is that because
he is the only person who can do this
job he feels like he'd regret it if he
just sat by and did nothing after
hearing this the principle of jujitsu
High enrolls Yuji as a first year
student alongside fusuguro and one other
person nobra kugisaki is the feisty new
student joining the class and one thing
you should know about her is that she's
from the countryside and therefore isn't
used to the kind of spirits that exist
in Tokyo this is why in episode 3 Gojo
tries to test nobra's skills by sending
harun Yuji into a haunted building once
they get inside the two students then
immediately split up with kukisaki being
unimpressed at how its story only
recently learned about curses despite
his inexperience though he still
exercises a Spirit by himself by using
this thing called a curse tool as the
name suggests curse tools are weapons
that have cursed energy flowing through
them and they can be used by literally
anyone to exercise a curse meanwhile on
the top floor of the building nobra is
put in a very tricky situation when a
low-level Spirit takes a child hostage
generally speaking highly populated
areas like Tokyo generate more curse
energy than the countryside and a
knock-on effect of this is that the
curses here are more intelligent this
curse was smart enough to recognize that
it couldn't beat kukasaki in a fight and
so instead it forces her to surrender by
threatening the boy in this moment she
accepts to herself that she's probably
not gonna make it however it has already
saved the day as he bursts through the
wall this gave no over an opening to
exercise the coast spirit and in the
aftermath she opens up to Yuji about the
reason she became a sorcerer when she
was younger a family from Tokyo moved
into her Village but were eventually
forced to leave after receiving abuse
from the locals one of the girls in that
family was nobra's best friend at the
time and ever since the incident
kugasaki has hated the countryside
transferring to Jujitsu high was the
only way for her to escape and by
arriving in Tokyo she hopes that someday
she'll bump into her old friend moving
on two weeks later nobra Yuji and
fushiguro are sent on a dangerous
mission where unfortunately one of them
ends up dead to understand how this
happened we need to realize that when
sukina came back to life it led to a
chain reaction in which his other 19
fingers were awakened as a result they
now produce even more curse energy than
usual and on this Mission the group
encounters a spirit that consumed one of
these supercharged fingers curse spirits
of this level would usually be dealt
with by someone like Gojo but on this
occasion he was away on business and
apparently no one else was free that's
why the first years were hand is such a
dangerous job and after arriving at the
scene nobra easily gets abducted and
thrown into a room full of cursed
Spirits at the same time Eugene fusuguro
are attacked by the curse I just
mentioned and they realize pretty
quickly that they're outmatched Yuji in
particular has his arm chopped off right
at the beginning of the fight while one
of fushiguro's divine dogs is Torn to
Pieces feeling desperate isidori decides
to ask sukuna for help but the king of
Crisis replies by threatening to murder
everyone here if he gets control of the
Body for that reason alone Yuji begs his
classmate to run as far away as possible
so that he can unleash sukuna without
having to worry about people being
killed after briefly hesitating fusuguro
agrees to this plan and he leaves the
area to go and find kugisaki his
remaining Divine dog has the ability to
track down anyone with a familiar scent
and so in around 5 minutes it leads them
straight to nobora if they'd arrived any
later she would have definitely been
eaten by this cast Spirit but fushigura
saves her life by using his frog
shikigami following that they completely
escaped the area with the unconscious
kukasaki being put in the back of a car
and driven straight to the hospital I
should point out that Megami also had
the option to go with her but instead he
chooses to stick around and wait for
Yuji to come back as he stands there
waiting for a few minutes so you could
have suddenly appears out of nowhere
having defeated the curse that was
causing them so much trouble unlike the
first episode though this time around
Yuji is struggling to regain control
giving sukuna a rare opportunity to just
do whatever he wants to start things off
he literally rips out itadori's heart
meaning that if they were to switch
places again Yuji would immediately die
the second thing he does is increase his
strength by eating another finger and
this finger is the one that he took from
the curse he just destroyed finally the
third thing as you can see is that he
regenerated yuji's seven arm thanks to
the power of reverse curse technique
reverse curse technique is a rare skill
that only the absolute one percent of
sorcerers can do and it involves turning
negative curse energy into positive
energy that can heal the body with all
that said sukina proceeds to give Mega
me the worst Beatdown of his life and
even blows out one of his shikigami in
the process as this one-sided Fight
Continues the king of curses gets
fascinated by Future guru's technique
and claims that 10 Shadows had the
potential to beat the curse Spirit from
earlier in spite of that Megami feels
like this fight is one he can't win and
so once again he prepares to sacrifice
himself by summoning his most dangerous
shikigami just like in episode 1 his
plan was for both himself and sukuna to
die here but before he goes through with
it we learn a little bit more about his
backstory in the recent past fushiguru's
sister fell into a deep coma and the
incident helped him to understand that
people get screwed over regardless of
whether they're good or bad therefore as
a sorcery he tries to make sure that the
good people suffer a tiny bit less which
is the reason he wanted to save Yuji
after hearing this itadori finally
retakes control back from tsukuna and
collapses on the ground without the need
for anyone to be sacrificed the next day
when goja returns from his trip he
immediately suspects the higher-ups of
organizing yuji's death while it's true
that they did agree to pause his
execution there were still many
higher-ups who wanted him gone and
sending First Years on a mission like
this was the perfect way to do it in
Gojo's mind these Elders are the scum of
the Jiu Jitsu world and his dream was to
raise a new generation of students that
could fundamentally change their society
Yuji was supposed to be a part of that
dream which is why he's so disappointed
but what Gojo didn't realize was that
itidori's Soul wasn't fully gone inside
the mind of every sorcerer there's a
place known as an innate domain and is
essentially a world that exists inside
their head when Yuji died his soul
entered sukune's innate domain giving
them one last chance to talk before he
disappears during this interaction the
king of curses offers to heal itsadory's
heart but only if they agreed to certain
conditions condition number one is that
at a time of sukiness using he can take
full control of yuji's body for 60
seconds by saying the word extension and
condition number two is that itadori
will forget they made this deal after
negotiating sukuna agrees not to hurt
anyone during those 60 seconds and so
the two of them form a binding vow
introduce you a binding vow is a
contract that literally can't be broken
and it's implied the reason sukuna
wanted this deal is because he's
plotting something to do with fushiguro
anyway back in the real world yuji's
body was seconds away from getting
dissected by shoko who's the main doctor
at Jiu Jitsu High however as Gojo
watches on itadori then resurrects in
front of their eyes creating a very
interesting situation as we know the
higher ups all believe that Yuji is dead
so if they found out that he was alive
then they might just try to Target him
again this is why Gojo and shoko agree
to keep his resurrection a secret so
that itadori has time to train before
anyone learns the truth later that same
night Yuji then gets taken to a random
basement somewhere where he begins
learning how to control purse energy
like I explained in the intro curse
energy comes from negative human
emotions but Jiu Jitsu Sorcerers are
trained to use it regardless of their
emotional state in order for Yuji to
learn the skill he's forced to watch a
ton of old movies and the challenge here
is to keep the negative energy flowing
irrespective of how the different movies
make him feel now while itadori is busy
with that Gojo leaves to have a meeting
with the principal and on the journey
there he senses that he's being followed
after leaving the car he's then ambushed
by a special great curse spirit and I'm
gonna quickly break down what that means
introduce you guys in Every curse is
given a ranking with grade 4 spirits
being the weakest and grade 1 spirits
being the strongest on rare occasions
though the recurse spirits so powerful
that they rank even above grade 1 and
it's these Elites that are referred to
as special grade the name of this
particular special grade is jogo and
he's a super intelligent curse that's
formed an alliance with other curses of
the same level their ultimate goal is
for curse spirits to become the dominant
life forms on the planet and to
accomplish that mission they need to get
rid of the strongest sorcerer what
follows this is jogo repeatedly trying
and failing to land a hit while Gojo
crushes him in the most disrespectful
way imaginable during the middle of the
fight he even teleports a way to grab
Yuji because he figured this would be a
good chance to teach a student about
domain expansions a domain expansion is
when someone uses massive amounts of
curse energy to bring their innate
domain into the real world the benefit
is that your opponents will be trapped
inside the barrier and any attack you
make against them is guaranteed to hit
the target for that reason expanding his
domain was jogo's best chance of Victory
but what he wasn't prepared for was Gojo
doing the exact same thing when two
domains are activated in the same space
the more polished domain will nearly
always override the other one and in
this case jogo loses instantly usually
this would be the part where he gets
exercised as well but Gojo decides to
temporarily spare his life so that he
can find out why the kirsh ambushed him
in the first place to be specific Gojo
wants to know who this special grade is
working with and I guess now is a good
time to explain the other members of
jogo's group to start with we have
Hanami who's an intelligent cursed
Spirit created from the fear that people
have of the forest because of why he was
born his technique lets him generate
flowers and other natural things that
you'd expect to find in a forest
environment next up we have Dagon who
was created from the fear that people
have of the ocean hence why his domain
expansion is this sunny beach after him
is mojito who's the leader of the group
and mojito is a spirit born from the
hatred that humans have towards each
other as a consequence mojito has a deep
understanding of how people think and
his technique enables him to transform
their soul in terrifying ways finally
the last member of this team is sugru
gaito who's a human Sorcerer And Gojo's
former best friend back in their younger
days they were classmates together at
Jiu Jitsu high and season 2 will show us
exactly what happened to their
relationship for now though all you have
to know is that everyone in the Jiu
Jitsu world thinks that Gator was dead
and they have no idea idea that he's
secretly working with these curse
Spirits switching back to drogo's battle
with Gojo you'll notice that in the
background two of his allies have been
watching him fight although neither of
them wanted to get involved Hanami
decides that he can't just stand back
and watch his fellow curse be destroyed
therefore he creates a big distraction
using his technique which gives Hanami a
small opening to swoop in and save
Joker's life this was a super risky move
since there was always a chance that
goja would have exercised them both but
luckily in this situation they do manage
to escape following that encounter the
special Rays realize that they don't
have what it takes to kill the strongest
sorcerer which to be fair is something
ghetto tried to tell them from the
beginning instead his idea to deal with
Gojo is to seal his former best friend
inside the prison realm which is a curse
object that traps its Target in another
dimension for the scheme to work though
there are certain preparations that gato
has to make which is why he says that
they should wait a few months until
October the 31st flashing forward to
September by this point you has been
secretly training for a while and he's
learned the basics of using curse energy
to test out his new skills Gojo sends
him on a mission with nanami who's a
grade one Sorcerer And one of the few
people that Gojo can trust together
their job is to investigate the murder
of three high school students who were
gruesomely disfigured in a local Cinema
the way they were killed means that a
curse spirit is likely responsible and
after looking into it now let me
discovers two things number one at the
time of the killings there was another
boy in the cinema called junpe who could
possibly be a witness number two whoever
the murderer is Left Behind obvious
Clues almost like they want to be found
the next day these Clues bring none of
me to a location in the sewer where he
comes face to face with mahito despite
being the leader of his group maito is a
relatively young curse who spends his
days experimenting on humans with his
technique luring nanami to the sewers
was just another one of those
experiments as he wanted to transform
the soul of a jiu jitsu sorcerer what
comes after this is one of the best
fights in season 1 one that ends in a
draw as mahito is crushed under a pile
of rubble while nanami escapes with a
non-life-threatening injury at the exact
same time Yuji approaches Jim pay to ask
him a few questions and it turns out the
boy is able to see curses back in the
cinema he witnessed mahito murdering his
classmates but rather than being scared
he wanted to know if he could learn the
same power in case you want to know why
he's like this dream pay is a character
who was severely bullied at school and
the cinema victims were three of the
bullies who made his life hell therefore
he didn't really care that they died and
after this incident mahito realized that
Jim pay could be useful to him remember
although the goal of mahitos group is
for curses to overthrow Humanity ceiling
goja was only one part of their plan the
second part is for sukuna to join their
side and to make this happen what they
need is a human who can get close to
Yuji this is where jumpee comes in
because in episode 11 mahito literally
tells him to make friends with anyone
wearing the Jiu Jitsu High uniform when
Jim pay then meet its Dory this is
exactly what happens as they form a
genuine connection over their love
movies in fact they get along so well
that usually gets invited round to his
house for dinner while off in the
distance ghetto is secretly observing
the whole thing later that evening it's
implied that he talks to mahito about
what he saw as they come up with a solid
strategy to get sukuna on their team
without going into all the details their
plan was to engineer a situation in
which Yuji would be forced to give
permanent control of his body to the
king of curses mahito believed that by
doing this favor for sukana he'd be more
likely to assist the group in their
mission to become the dominant life
forms the very next day this plan is
then set into motion as jumpy gets
brutally disfigured right in front of
yuji's eyes naturally itadori doesn't
have any powers to change his friend
back to normal and so he begs sukuna for
help and offers up his entire body in
exchange for saving dream pay of course
this outcome is exactly what mahito was
hoping would happen but in a shocking
ton of events the king of curses chooses
not to accept the deal part of the
reason he says no is that he just enjoys
seeing Yuji suffer but another reason is
that they already made a deal that will
let him take over whenever he needs to
on top of that it's unclear whether
reverse curse technique can cure someone
whose Soul has been manipulated and so
yeah just overall it wasn't the best
deal for sukuna as a result Jim pay
drops dead right there and then causing
Yuji to lose his mind as he tries to get
revenge against mahito throughout his
fight with the special grade we learned
that because its Dory has two Souls
inside him it makes him naturally
resistant to mitos technique what this
means is that his soul can't be
destroyed in the same way as other
people and he can physically damage the
curse in a way that nanami wasn't able
to speaking of not in me he then shows
up at the location and the two Sorcerers
work together to crush the special grade
to the point where he's about to be
exercised unfortunately though this
near-death experience causes mahito to
evolve as he triggers his domain
expansion for the first time ever the
main benefit of this bar area is that
mojito can destroy the soul of anyone
trapped inside and in this case he
decides to only trap nonami since Yuji
having two Souls is a bit of a problem
being realistic this was actually the
smartest thing mojito could have done
but what he wasn't prepared for was that
its Dory would be crazy enough to break
into his domain breaking into this
barrier from the outside is a thing that
no sane person would ever think about
but by usually doing this it meant that
mahito's domain accidentally made
contact with sukuna's soul the king of
curses is someone with huge amounts of
Pride and having his soul touched in
this way is something that he didn't
really appreciate also he genuinely
doesn't care about anyone else except
himself and mega me and so for that
reason tsukuna blows up mahito's domain
the fight is then basically over after
that as the special raid runs away into
the sewers while the sorcerers try and
fail to chase after him anyway moving
back to jiu jitsu high for the past
month Mega me and kugasaki had been
training for the Goodwill event once a
year students from
face off against students from Kyoto Jiu
Jitsu high in what's supposed to be a
friendly competition on both sides you
have quite a few interesting students
but for the purpose of this video I'm
just going to take you through the five
characters who will be most relevant to
the plot first off in the Tokyo school
we have Maki Xenon who's a second year
student and member of the zenin
bloodline in the world of Jiu Jitsu the
zening clan on one of the most
influential families alongside the Gojo
Clan and the camo Clan however Marquee
is basically treated by everyone in her
family as a failure since she was born
with a rare condition known as Heavenly
restriction Heavenly restriction is when
a sorcerer is born with a defect in
exchange for being extremely talented in
some other way when it comes to Maki she
was born without a single drop of curse
energy which is even less than the
average person but in exchange she has
superhuman strength on a similar level
to Yuji panda is another second year
student at Tokyo and he's a rare type of
creature referred to as a cursed corpse
to put it simply a cursed corpse is an
inanimate object that is brought to life
when someone puts cursed energy inside
it most of the time these corpses are
only able to function as long as they
keep receiving cursed energy but panda
is different from this since he's able
to generate his own curse energy like a
regular human as a brief side note Panda
was the creation of principal Yaga who's
the guy that runs Tokyo Jiu Jitsu High
switching over to the Kyoto school we
have my Xenon who's the twin sister of
Marquee and someone who never wanted to
be a sorcerer it was only when Maki
joined Jiu Jitsu high that Mai was
pressured to go down a similar path and
as you can imagine they don't really get
along one of my's classmates at Kyoto is
a robot called Mecca Maru but in reality
the robot is controlled by a real person
just like Marquis this guy was born with
Heavenly restriction meaning that in
exchange for being heavily disabled he
has massive amounts of curse energy and
a long range technique that lets him
control puppets finally the last person
I want to mention for now is Toto who is
by far the strongest student at Kyoto
and he's an interesting guy who loves to
fight hates boring people doesn't listen
to instructions is obsessed with a pop
star and thinks of himself as extremely
intelligent on the day of the Goodwill
event he and his classmates travel to
Tokyo to take part in a team battle
against kushuguro's group however just
before it gets underway Gojo turns up
with a surprise for everyone as he
dramatically reveals that Yuji is still
alive given that it's been about two
months since he died Mega me and
kugasaki had finished grieving him a
long time ago and so their initial
reaction wasn't as excited as he was
expecting regardless they were both
happy to have him back although there's
one person who didn't exactly feel the
same way principal gakuganji is the
Headmaster of the Kyoto school and is
one of the old higher-ups that wanted
Yuji to be executed after finding out
that sukuna's vassal isn't dead Gaga
ganji holds an emergency meeting with
his students where he orders them to
kill itadori for a second time in
particular he wants the killing to take
place during the good will event in a
way that makes it look like an accident
meanwhile as if that wasn't enough drama
in a separate area of the school mojito
had managed to sneak in to understand
why we need to flash back to the moment
when sukina casually destroyed his
domain expansion it was thanks to this
humiliation the magito realized the king
of curses is way stronger than he ever
imagined in fact suken's strength was so
overwhelming that the curse Spirits
don't even want him to join their team
anymore instead all they want is to
bring him back to life as they believe
that he'll begin a new era of curses all
by himself this is where Jiu Jitsu High
comes in because hidden somewhere inside
the school as six of sukh and his
fingers so far in the series Yuji has
ever only consumed one finger at a time
which has enabled him to retain some
level of control however things would be
different if he was forced to eat six or
more in one go that's why gato suggested
that they steal them from Jiu Jitsu high
so that on October the 31st they'll be
able to unleash and seal Gojo on the
same day okay now one thing I should
probably mention before we continue is
that inside the school there's a 1 000
year old sorcerer who protects the curse
objects the name of this sorcerer is
tengen and for now all you need to know
about this character is that she is the
only one who knows where sukiness
fingers are stored normally it would be
impossible for anyone else to find them
but luckily gaito had thought of a way
around this during their jump history
line gato actually had a finger of his
own and he strategically planted it
somewhere where he knew Jiu Jitsu high
would find it as expected the school
then took the curse object and placed it
with the others but what they didn't
know is that it had a Tracker with
Mojito's curse energy inside it this
meant that mojito would easily be able
to find the secret room and while he's
doing that part of me and a couple of
Assassins will create a big distraction
back to the Goodwill event by this point
in the team battle kugasaki was defeated
by Mai Mai was then defeated by Marquis
and Kamara was defeated by Panda and
yujian Toto somehow became best friends
unlike the rest of his school Toto
didn't have any desire to kill its Dory
and as the two of them started fighting
he realized that they liked the same
type of girl as a result he protected
his new best friend from being executed
and begins teaching Yuji a lesson about
how to harness curse energy more
efficiently while that craziness was
going on Megami was involved in a fight
of his own against a student who has a
lot of political importance Naruto
shikamo is a third year student at Kyoto
high and next in line to be leader of
the Como Clan I mentioned earlier that
the Carmo Clan is equal to the Gojo
clown and the zening clan meaning
narutoshi himself is a future higher-up
of the Jiu Jitsu World despite that he
has a super complicated family situation
which is why he feels like he can relate
to a fushiguro 11 years ago fushuguro's
dad disappeared Without a Trace and Gojo
stepped in to essentially become his new
legal guardian what makes this
complicated is that megany's father was
from the zening clan meaning that
fushuguru is a sorcerer with Zen in
blood but who's more closely associated
with the gojos anyway during his fight
with narutoshi things get interrupted
when Hanami shows up the special grade
attacks them so badly that Megami thinks
about sacrificing himself for the third
time but he chooses not to when some
other Tokyo students come to help
gradually the battle keeps evolving
until Yuji and Toto were the main ones
fighting hard of me and they're able to
deal a good amount of damage Toto's
curse technique lets him switch places
with anything that has a certain amount
of curse energy and so he constantly
confuses the special raid by changing
positions at the same time Yuji is now a
lot stronger thanks to his new best
friend and he punches hanmi with an
attack known as black flash black flash
is a rare thing that happens when
Sorcerers are fully in tune with their
curse energy and increases the strength
of their attacks by more than double
together Yuji and Toto Force Hanami into
a desperate situation where he felt like
his best offering to survive was to
activate his domain expansion however
before he gets the chance to activate it
Saturday or Gojo finally makes an
appearance up until this moment he'd
been unable to join the the fight
because the villains had made a barrier
out of curse energy that specifically
prevented him from coming in barriers
like this are referred to as curtains
and the rules of the curtain will vary
depending on who created it in this case
the Only Rule of this barrier was that
Gojo wasn't allowed to enter but
everyone else was free to come in or out
whenever they wanted this was a genius
move because it meant the satra focused
all his energy on getting inside rather
than paying attention to the fact that
the school was getting robbed regardless
he kind of Saves the Day by crippling
one of the assassins and blowing a huge
trunk out of the forest That was
supposed to kill Hanami honestly the
damage here was so extensive that nobody
could really tell whether the spirit was
dead or alive but later that day we find
out that the special grade did barely
manage to escape following this incident
the Goodwill event is on the verge of
being canceled but Toto manages to
persuade the other Shooters to continue
that's why the next day the two schools
have a baseball match to determine the
winner with Yuji helping Tokyo in a big
way to come out on top although the
higher ups do still want him dead
principal Yaga convinces principal
gakuganji to hold off for now As itadori
proved that he has the potential to save
lives in the future later that week the
first years is sent on a brand new
mission where they investigate the
mysterious deaths of four people the
four victims all used to be classmates
over 20 years ago and coincidentally the
school they went to is where Mega me
used to go before Jiu Jitsu high as part
of the investigation fujiguro Pays His
Old School to visit where a member of
staff and a couple other students give
us some relevant information near the
local area there's a famous haunted
place called yasohachi bridge and 20
years ago four students were found
unconscious in this exact spot when the
kids woke up they had no recollection of
what happened but now in the present day
all four were recently murdered by a
curse Spirit the main question for jiu
jitsu high is whether the curse spirit
will Target anyone else next and this is
where fujinuma comes in fujinuma is one
of megami's old classmates and she
reveals that during her child her she
visited yasohachi Bridge along with
fushiguro's sister what this means is
that based on all the evidence so far
the curse that killed those four men
will likely go after fujinuma and sumiki
within the next one or two weeks
therefore in order to save their lives
it's important that the spirit is
exercised as soon as humanly possible
which is why the first years arrive at
the bridge pretty soon the three of them
then walk into a barrier made of curse
energy and once inside they get
confronted by a creature they've never
faced before for a bit of context here
150 years ago there was an evil sorcerer
called Naruto shikamo who was the
ancestor of the narutoshi in the present
day the old narutoshi was Infamous for
his disgusting experiments one of which
was to create a life form that was both
half human and half-cur spirit in total
he made nine of these hybrids and the
official name for them is the curse womb
death paintings for decades all nine
death paintings were hidden inside Jiu
Jitsu high in the same storeroom as sukh
and his fingers when mojito robbed the
school he took 3 three of the death
paintings with him and with gato's help
chozo ESO and kijisu were brought back
to life in new bodies despite them being
hybrids The Three Brothers feel no
loyalty towards humans Orca Spirits as
the only thing they care about is
protecting each other for that reason
they do agree to help mahito because the
world he's trying to create is one where
the death paintings might be able to
live in peace following that ASO and
kijisu were sent on a mission to find
one of sukuni's missing fingers which
just so happens to be under yasohachi
bridge this is what leads to a fight
between the death paintings and yujisaki
while megamese left a fight against the
curse that they came here to kill a long
time ago this curse Spirit had absorbed
one of sukin's fingers but for a while
nothing happened because the fingers
weren't awakened however once sukuna was
reincarnated a few months ago all the
fingers woke up and the curse of
yasohachi bridge then became active this
means that the recent death of those
four adults and the upcoming death of
samiki it can all be traced back to
yuji's decision to eat the cursed object
anyway it goes without saying that the
cursed Spirit of yasohachi bridge was
incredibly strong even more so than the
one they faced earlier in the series
within seconds it almost instantly
knocks bushid girl unconscious and puts
him in a situation where he doesn't have
much hope of survival that's why for the
fourth time this season he gets ready to
sacrifice himself by summoning a
shikigami that he knows will kill them
both before he fully summons it though
he remembers something that was said to
him by two of the strongest Sorcerers of
all time as we know sukuna outright
stated that Megami has the potential to
beat curses like this while goju
encouraged his student to abandon this
sacrificial mentality that keeps holding
him back therefore instead of just
sacrificing himself pushuguru chooses to
go all out as he attempts to manifest
his domain in the real world only
Sorcerers of the highest level can do
this and while Megami isn't on that
level yet he's able to create an
incomplete domain expansion within this
shadowy domain he can create clone of
himself and clones of his shikigami
which are used to overwhelm the special
great spirit he then finishes It Off by
activating his Divine dog which brutally
rips out sukuna's finger from inside the
spirit's chest in the end the result of
this fight is that sumiki and fujinuma
are no longer going to die from the
curse of the bridge but unfortunately
his sister is still in a coma due to a
completely separate curse that she also
has meanwhile Yuji and kugisaki kill the
two death paintings and this was
impressive since Azo and his brother
were technically special grade curses
after the incident itadori feels
slightly guilty for what happened given
that they ended the lies of two actual
human beings who clearly cared about
each other a lot although the eldest
sibling chozo wasn't there his curse
technique allowed him to sense that his
siblings were killed ghetto then reveals
to him that it was Yuji who killed them
and this scene is super important for
two reasons number one ghetto receiving
this Intel so quickly proves Beyond any
doubt that their Summoner Jiu Jitsu High
whose feeding him information number two
the death of chozo's Brothers gives him
a real motivation to go after Yuji which
should be explored in the next season a
few days later word begins to spread
about how the first years each defeated
a special grade and this leads to a
couple different consequences for a
start Toto makes an official
recommendation that they be promoted to
grade 1 Sorcerers and his recommendation
is supported by one of Gojo's friends
who may or may not have been paid by
Gojo to do this another thing is that
the second years begin training even
harder than before since Maki is
determined not to fall behind her cousin
fushiguro and the other two first-year
students on top of that although the
recent deaths were kind of itadori's
fault Megami and nobra agreed not to
tell him since they think that he might
not be able to deal with the guilt that
being said an interesting plot twist is
that Yuji does actually know it was his
fault but he chooses not to say anything
because he doesn't want fushiguro to
feel regret for saving his life season 1
then comes to an end with the first is
going shopping before Gojo unexpectedly
calls them for what he describes as a
top secret mission with that said that
was the whole of jjk season 1 explained
in around 30 minutes although I think
this might end up actually being closer
to 40. if you enjoyed this video then
I'd really appreciate if you subscribe
so you don't miss out on future content
like this and hit that like button as it
does help out with the algorithm until
the next one peace out